the gyro can experience that's the
problem with history right it's like who
knows what the [ __ ] Lincoln said all we
know is what Lincoln wrote okay when you
have Lincoln holding hands with his
boyfriend going for a walk through the
garden [ __ ] you just making [ __ ] up you
make that a thing now well there are
there is speculation that Abraham
Lincoln was a gay man and they slept
with a man for long periods of time in
the same bed but apparently people did
that very often back then for warmth
because you know you lived in a place
that was made out of wood
that you chopped down your [ __ ] himself
it should have been for four years oh
listen ice cold for four years in a row
I'd be tough to share a bed with Lincoln
he was [ __ ] huge yeah he's all strong
too it's a wrestler was he yeah huh yeah
he was an excellent wrestler suppose any
shared a bed with his captain captain of
his bodyguards whenever his wife was
away hip hop hooray
so maybe hey it might be both me no we
have to you know think about it in
context right I think if you go back to
the Greeks and the Romans gay sex was
way more common I mean it was like
almost like everybody was half gay right
yeah no and pedophilia was just a normal
thing young boys like if you read
Socrates you read the history of him or
of a lot of scholars and like really
respected thinkers they had young boys
but they would bang so what was what
today is a horrific crime against
humanity was completely normal back then
yeah so when did that stop when did do
is to stop banging dudes and did they
just kind of do it and not talk about it
or was it it seems like Christianity
first brought about the shame the sexual
shame that we have today so I would
probably trace it back to like 2,000
years ago if you hum here's the question
how much of being gay is stopped by
society's ex
vacations like what is the percentage of
people who are actually gay who just
can't act on it because it just it but
their mom or their religion or their
church they go to or they're you know
they got married and they had kids but
they really want to be gay how much of
that exists today
look what percentage out of all all the
gay activity if you can put it on a pie
chart
you mean how many more gay people would
there be if they didn't
there was just no one form - yeah
there's no limitations from religion no
expectations from your community hi bien
would you [ __ ] yeah do you think you'd
be a top or a bottom top that's what
everybody thinks I'd be a screaming
bottom lot of crying waterboarding I'd
be a running bottom just like when
you're waterboarded you'd be [ __ ] the
spasming uncontrollably it turns that
there's that that's what a lot of the
guys are into unfortunately just sets
the bigotry community waterboard he's a
runner what [ __ ] getting butt-fucked
by waterboarding it's the new black it's
the new thing yeah it's the rage it's
all the rage nipple clamps and mmm